hey guys I'm Ryan Wright I'm gonna be
watching the Great Dictator speech
Charlie Chaplin plus time Hans Zimmer
inception theme I've seen the speech
before I like this beach it's very
motivating this is so old the speech
itself and yet it applies so much to
today I'm interested in seeing like how
much more motivating this could be
because I don't know how audiences like
people in my age my demographic would
respond to this speech today but I think
it's something so powerful I think when
adding that like Hans Zimmer touch to it
making it feel a little bit more modern
day I think it will be even a more
powerful way to communicate to people
nowadays is the first time I watch the
speech it was like yes [ __ ] yeah we need
to be free and and then think better and
the feel better like we need to just
know how to focus and we need to know
how to be self-motivated and we have to
know how to just create like there's so
much in that speech that I really do
adore so let's check this out
I'm sorry I don't want to be an emperor
that's not my business I don't want to
rule or conquer anyone
I should like to help everyone if
possible Jew Gentile black man white we
all want to help one another human
beings are like that we want to live by
each other's happiness not by each
other's misery we don't want to hate and
despise one another in this world is
room for everyone of the good earth is
rich and can provide for everyone the
way of life can be free and beautiful
but we have lost the way greed has
poisoned men's souls has barricaded the
world with hate has goose-stepped us
into misery and bloodshed
we have developed speed but we have shut
ourselves in machinery that gives
abundance has left us in want our
knowledge has made us cynical our
cleverness hard and unkind we think too
much
little more than machinery we need
humanity more than cleverness we need
kindness and gentleness without these
qualities life will be violent and all
will be lost the aeroplane and the radio
have brought us closer together and very
nature of these inventions cries out for
the goodness in men cries out for
universal brotherhood for the unity of
us all even now my voice is reaching
millions throughout the world millions
of despairing men women individual
victims of a system that makes me
those who can hear me I say do not
despair the misery that is now upon us
is but the passing of green
the bitterness of men who fear the way
of human progress the hate of men will
pass and dictators die and the power
they took from the people will return to
the people and so long as men die
Liberty will never perish
soldiers don't give yourselves to brutes
men who despise you enslave you who
regiment your lives tell you what to do
but to think about the feel who drill
you diet you treat you like little use
yourselves to these unnatural men
machine men with machine minds the
machine hearts
you're not machines
you have a love of humanity in your
hearts you don't hate Jesus make you
honor the unnatural soldiers don't fight
for slavery fight for liberty in the 70%
of it is written for making the
this wooden man not one man nor a group
of men but in all men me you you the
people have the power to create machines
the power to create happiness you the
people have the power to make this life
free and beautiful to make this life a
wonderful adventure in the name of
democracy let us use that power let us
all unite
the world that will give men a chance to
work that will give you the future and
old age a security
- of these things
but they lie they do not fulfill the
promise they never will
free themselves but they enslave the
people now it is straight to fulfill
that promise
that is straight to free the world to do
away with national barriers to do away
with greed with in a tenant turrets
reason where science and progress will
lead to all men's happiness
soldiers in the name of democracy let us
all unite
there's some powerful [ __ ] dude god I
love that speech it's so empowering like
I was talking with ELISA ELISA be crazy
yesterday and Veronica a few years back
this is when I started becoming
interested in history I was at my
ex-girlfriends camping trip with her
church I'm not part of it like a
religion I'm not a theist but I don't
consider myself belonging to a
particular religion but there was a
Bible teaching going on like there was a
pastor there there's a Bible teaching I
decided to sit in on it one person asked
if Jesus really was real how come he
doesn't perform these miracles today and
this was on a camping trip my first time
going camping and then it just like
sparked a bunch of thoughts of how
amazing it is where humans have just
come from I think it's incredible you
take race out of the equation you just
go human race not Asian or blacks human
race and you take like what it was just
like a couple hundred years ago and I
think like if you time-traveled back to
like the Jesus days and you showed them
like what a cellphone is they'd be like
that's a miracle it wasn't that long ago
where you tell people what a plane is
and though they would think that's a
miracle if we were able to actually do
that so it sounds cheesy and corny but
when you look at where we come from like
if you're one of those people who's like
human beings are part of the animal
kingdom too if you look at all the other
animals like we have this ability to
create we have this ability to think
that's why we're dominating and that's
why we can eat meat cuz we dominate
animals animals don't have a soul now I
love animal that medic is a friend of
mine you said that the other day knows
like whoa okay you should watch louis
c.k stand-up called hilarious everything
I've ever thought is like all in that
one stand-up and this speech too is like
there's a 1-point breeze talking about
how you know there's things that provide
us abundance yet they're causing us like
distance in a way I don't remember the
exact line but it just got me thinking
about that like how we are surrounded by
so much that's grating yet we don't
appreciate
you know that sounds so cliche to say
but it's it's so true the fact that I'm
able to communicate to you guys on this
thing called the Internet the World Wide
Web is a [ __ ] miracle when you look
at it like not that long ago people be
like impossible it's it's insane and
Will Smith's words of wisdom check that
video out too I love hearing stuff like
this like some people might not get the
idea that I do but I actually listen to
a lot of like personal development CDs
and books and I love speeches like this
like so yeah this is really worth it
even the year is wrapping up right now
and I think watching this was just a
great way to remind myself to just keep
being free keep being creative and just
keep being myself and keep going for
stuff I hope this speech communicates to
a lot of people you know like I think
about how people will hear a quote I'm
the kind of guy that could quote a bunch
of people because I live by a lot of
quotes I think about those people who
like hear a quote and they post it on
their Facebook and they're like oh what
a nice quote they only like that quote
when times are good but those really
inspiring motivational quotes need to be
applied most when times are not so great
because life is that emotional
rollercoaster so you need to know how to
apply it and pick yourself back up and
keep going and keep moving this whole
speech and backed up with the Hansa
where music just makes it that much
better so yeah like I hope this really
reaches a lot more people I think
there's a beautiful speech still
powerful to this day like it just long
lasting stamps a test of time yeah thank
you
there's several people who kept asking
camera names right now but thank you
guys for really pushing me to watch this
video great way to wrap up the year and
if you guys are new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects where
we are are double e REO this show get
stupider by the second I'm gonna be
starting up shoutouts again in the new
year so go to facebook.com slash the
real reject shout outs say something
interesting and earn yourself a shout
out from this good-looking [ __ ]
with a huge dick and quite the most
spread out [ __ ] in the world uh I
could be a motivational speaker